un avion des nations unies se pose sur
l'aéroport de pemba à son bord des
adultes et des enfants originaires de
palma dans le nord est du pays depuis
mercredi cette ville le théâtre d'une
violente attaque d'un groupe djihadiste
et c'était un moment horrible un vrai
massacre aucun d'entre nous n'a meurent
et y retourner beaucoup de gens sont
morts
nous sommes allés à l'hôtel amaru là où
nous sommes restés deux ou trois jours
encerclé par les terroristes
après quatre jours sans manger nous
avons décidé de partir et d'aller dans
la forêt pour nous échapper
certains collègues blancs ont perdu la
vie la défense mozambicaine a fait état
dimanche soir de dizaines de morts parmi
les habitants de palma au moins une
centaine de personnes restent portées
disparues et des milliers d'autres sont
enfuis dans cette ville qui comptait
plus de 70000 habitants avant l'attaqué
de mercredi dernier une attaque
revendiquée ce lundi par les djihadistes
du groupe al soud un hommage à meaux ou
al shebab affiliés à des ch
ils contrôleraient désormais banques
bureaux gouvernementaux usines et
casernes de l'armée de palma une ville
stratégique située à seulement dix
kilomètres à peine d'un méga projet
gazier de plusieurs milliards d'euros
piloté par le groupe français total le
géant énergétique qui espérait une
reprise des travaux de construction du
site a finalement renoncé
l'organisation des nations unies s'est
dit lundi je cite profondément préoccupé
par la situation toujours en évolution à
palma tandis que washington de son côté
déclare être déterminé à assister le
gouvernement mozambicain pour lutter
contre le djihadiste sens pour leur
préciser de quelle manière le portugal
qui gardent des relations privilégiées
avec son ancienne colonie a annoncé
l'envoi d'une soixantaine de militaires
dans les prochaines semaines